I just felt like the wedding was so
stressful and one day Ben just says
okay let's just go to Vegas and get
married tonight and I was like it was
that day
Jennifer Lopez spills all the details
about her Las Vegas elopement with her
now hubby Ben Affleck what can I tell
you we're just having a good time yeah a
month before their lavish wedding in
Georgia the couple tied the knot in an
intimate ceremony at a private Vegas
chapel and JLo tells Jimmy Kimmel how it
all went down and everybody was kind of
chill you know nobody was freaking out
or anything but they were talking to us
they were like hey what are you doing
here
we went over to the chapel they were
waiting for us at the chapel they knew
we were coming they're like somebody's
coming at midnight can you stay open
they were like yes we'll stay open till
midnight do you need Elvis we said no we
don't need the elevator you know it's
wild to think about it that way so if
they had a big bash planned in Georgia
why the Vegas elopement
if her and Ben's
which ended in 2004. it was my first
kind of heartbreak yeah that heartbreak
had JLo feeling a little overwhelmed the
second time around it was so stressful
and a month before and I don't know if
you guys know this but 20 years ago we
were supposed to get married I'd heard
I've read that I think
they all fell apart back then and this
time it was like we still had a life ABS
absolutely that had a little PTSD so
what does Ben Do Well turns out he's the
one who came up with the idea to get
married in Sin City so I was just like
what's is this happening is this really
happening and we were so happy and of
course it was happening but I just felt
like the wedding was so stressful and
one day Ben just says
okay let's just go to Vegas and get
married tonight as for who attended well
two of their five kids were there while
the other three were away at summer camp
he's like they're gonna be our Witnesses
let's go we're doing it tonight and we
did it seems like it was the right
decision it was amazing it was amazing
it was the best night you still believe
in love you believe in marriage you
still believe in all of those absolutely
why wouldn't I following the Vegas
ceremony the lovebirds went through with
that magical Georgia wedding and as
Ben's longtime pal and collaborator
Kevin Smith told E.T it was pretty
special it was absolutely beautiful uh
you know she's got impeccable taste so
the whole wedding looks fantastic he's
never been happier I've seen that dude
be happy but the pure joy that was like
radiating from his face it was
absolutely Unforgettable E.T spoke with
Jen this week while promoting her latest
flick shotgun wedding where she and her
co-star Josh dumel couldn't help but
gush over Jen's true leading man Ben
what's the best part of this chapter and
and you know being married to Ben
there's so many things I mean I I
couldn't I you don't have enough time
right now
well give me one oh look at that that's
that's a good that's a good version
no I got you I I hear you let me tell
you about my relationship with that I
was gonna say well give me
give me Josh
have you ever met him in person I have
it's a beautiful place he's a beautiful
man he's dreaming
foreign